-I think it's very true to say
that show business
can be a very fake place.
I do think that's one of
the realest nights insofar as
you spend a lot of time
talking to people
you're a genuine fan of,
and it's a night
that allows you to express that.
And I've had very cool
conversations with, you know,
people I never
would have met otherwise.
Where, they're in a show that
I, you know, genuinely love,
and to go over
and be able to tell them
is a really cool part
of the night.
-Sure. You know, when it's real,
like you haven't seen someone
for a long time,
and it's so great to see them
and it's so great
to congratulate them.
-You know, there's always
that clock of when you,
not that I would know,
but when you win,
there's a clock that
starts counting down.
And so you know you only
have 30 seconds left.
The other clock is anytime
you start talking to someone
you can't believe
you're talking to.
It's like 15 seconds
until a weirdo interrupts.
[ Laughs ]
-Correct.
Or you feel -- you feel them
like right here,
kind of like hovering,
hovering, right?
Or else it's like -- and then
it's also, see, I do find things
like award shows very
interesting, because, like,
you get to see
one's own ego at play,
and just, like, a social dynamic
that is crazy to see.
Because you're constantly
moving in, like,
high-low, high-low,
high-low, high-low.
And then you have to
kind of stay firm
to, like, what your position is.
It's like, oh, someone else,
more -- oh, Lady Gaga's passing.
-[ Laughs ]
-Okay, so she's --
You know what I mean?
So there's always...
I don't want to use the word
as hard as hierarchy,
but there is a hierarchy
that is constantly moving,
and you've got to kind of
figure out your play.
So that's why -- that's why I've
actually seen people that I know
that I like that I have some
sort of like relationship with.
It's really, really
kind of great to see
because it's really
super grounding.
-It is. I think that's
a really nice way of putting it.
You and I have something else --
we have very little in common
because you're such an
accomplished actor and I'm not.
But we have both worked --
we both worked with
the great Garry Marshall,
who was one of the, like,
warmest souls in the world.
-Yes.
-And your work in
"The Princess Diaries"
has come back around recently.
You have a wonderfully delivered
line in the film
about how the Queen
is coming to the school.
And I know you talked about this
recently on "Graham Norton,"
but now people are lip-syncing
to your scene on TikTok in a way
that the scene did not inform
how people
would choose to do this.
-Someone sent that to me,
and I could not believe it.
And it's this
great kind of TikTok --
I don't even know
what to call it.
This TikTok string, chain.
I didn't even know what it is,
but it's on TikTok,
and it takes one line
that Vice Principal Gupta,
who I played in the film,
and people seem to be
just taking that one line,
because my character is
talking on the phone.
And instead of the phone,
they use something else.
-Yeah.
-And it's freaking hilarious.
And it's actually
a really good line
to do something like that with.
-It's a really good line.
People are using --
We'll show a clip of one,
but people are using their pets.
-Yes.
[ Telephone ringing ]
-Gupta.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
The Queen is coming.
-I went back
and re-watched the line.
It is, I hope you know --
It's so perfectly delivered.
I mean, do you ever look back?
Now that it's like...
-No.
-...becoming this viral moment,
do you just think like,
"Thank God I nailed that line
with the precision --"
-You know what? No.
And going back to just a little
bit about Garry Marshall,
I remember the main and only
direction he gave to me --
this might be familiar to you.
He would go,
"Come here. Come here.
Go out and make funny, huh?
Go out and make funny."
And I will always remember it
because he gave me
a lot of freedom.
-Yeah.
-He gave me a lot of freedom
to try and be
as funny as possible.
But I've also --
So, yeah. I actually,
honestly, have not seen it.
I haven't seen that
in a long time.
But I really enjoy
how people enjoy it.
And people, I will say,
in the past --
now it's something
totally different --
but in the past, young people
or young people, like,
who are in their 20s
at that point,
would come up to me
and just say, "Oh, my God."
And they would do the line.
So I'm like, "Oh, my goodness.
Did this line hit for, like,
you know, 8-year-olds,
and now they're grown or maybe
now they're the people
who are like, you know,
wanting to --
-Yeah, it's really amazing
to think that you're doing
a piece of work, you know,
for the purpose at hand then,
but you're also planting
this seed
that you're completely
unaware of,
because of however it was that
they, you know, took it in
the first time they saw it,
and now it's just like
planting this wonderful new life
for this one line in a movie.
-Yes, it's a full story.
I think that's also why it is,
is in that line,
is that you have a full story.
It's a good comedic-written
scene, and I guess you're right.
It's like -- because you just
have these different beats
of how can you do it, and even
if you just look directionally,
with the beats,
you can make some of them fun.
-Well, I hope retroactively --
I'm very happy for
your Emmy nomination.
I hope retroactively you will
get an Oscar nomination
for that role if they ever
start doing that.
And thank you. It's always
so great to see you, Sandra.
-Same, same, what a pleasure.